[Music]
my name is Kelly I'm 25 years old I work
at a publishing company as a graphic
designer
my name is Eric I'm 27 and I'm a graphic
designer I work in a media company
[Music]
have you experienced anything sexist at
a job I experienced sexist things unlike
a minute-to-minute basis offhanded
comments or like assumptions like men
sometimes treating me like I like I'm
lost or confused and maybe I'm like did
you negotiate your pain I only did it
once at my last company and the first
time I went in to do it I chickened out
and didn't actually ask for the ring
really yeah I'm not good at that kind of
stuff yeah it's hard for me to like
equate money to what you're doing
there's so many other factors it's like
how much are people around you making
what's the market rate for this like how
much are other graph design you know and
it's so it's hard to kind of get in that
headspace to be like I deserve yeah five
thousand more dollars I feel like you
deserve it I hope I can get there so
yeah I know what about you I did it
didn't like work that well they made me
an offer and I was like that's absurd
and I tried to go up about like six or
seven and they went up to they like came
back and they're like this was the most
I can give you it was more than I had
been making at my last job where I did
not negotiate do you feel like you're
paid what you deserve
no it's hard to feel like you deserve
something and at least as a woman
there's this like sort of imposter
syndrome that you have going into a
career where you know you feel like how
did I get this job like am i doing what
I'm doing like what am I doing here yeah
I have hard-core imposter syndrome I
don't know who it would ever employ me
or like how I'm even working but I'm
happy with the salary I think I have
right now it's more money than I've made
in my life do I deserve it is that the
question I feel like I'm paid more than
I deserve
[Music]
three-two-one
[Laughter]
it's actually about what I expected
yeah yeah I expected that to be much
higher Wow
I warned you I mean you are a couple
years older than me it's true yeah but I
know that in a couple years I will not
be making that amount are you going to
approach your future job searches
differently after this what I really
want more than anything is to like
believe that what I'm asking for is what
I deserve because I feel like even when
I negotiate in the past or like um do
you think maybe like I know that but
like do you think it's like I don't want
to be like that right you want to say
like this is what I want
totally how does this change your
perspective on the pay gap it just makes
it more real for me I think and it's
something that's just not talked about
that much or express that much so as a
man especially kind of go your day to
day without thinking about it yeah so
just to talk to someone very intimately
and honestly it makes us seem so much
more urgent and real I agree that it
does feel more urgent in a way are you
glad you did this yes I am glad I did
this it's a really important
conversation to have it's a conversation
that's not happening if I can contribute
in any way to like awareness and truth
then I want to be a part of that and
that's the reason I said yes to this
totally everything you said
[Music]